I'm a true feminist I'm very happy to be
a woman and very proud to be a woman
I don't mind jokes about with me because
I will laugh at men I think it's only
fair that's very easy penises are funny
continue well I've seen men naked yeah
that's funny it's not even the same
color as the rest of our body yeah we
got a giggle out of it
glad to have our next guest a lot of you
probably aren't necessarily familiar
with her work but I she reached out to
me online and I was just really
compelled by the story her name is Tony
and she's the founder of Maria's which
is an acronym we're not talking about
West Side Story so Tony thanks for
coming on and why don't you tell our
listeners to the Marley's were dead to
begin with what it is that you do and a
little bit about Maria's because every
time every time men tried to do
something there was automatically
demonized by the far left right and I
also thought that season is when it
comes to a certain religion of peace
women tend to be the ones that are gonna
be in the most amount of danger and we
have over a million predominately white
girls that have been raped by Pakistani
Muslim men now this is Europe can am I
allowed to disclose the general area as
to where you're calling from
sorry night ended the phrase with from
that must offend the founders of the
English language like yourself I should
not have ended with the presupposition
you're around London so when you say
predominantly white women who've been
raped by Pakistani men are you talking
about England specifically London mostly
England England as a whole Rotherham
Peterborough towsley Stevenage
rock-style Bradford Birmingham the list
is endless
Liverpool Liverpool Manchester Leicester
because we don't think a lot you know I
guess sort of what I know of Manchester
my wife spent quite a bit of time in the
UK and I have some friends from there
you know you think of Manchester is more
of a sort of a working-class area and I
think Americans would think of areas
outside of London as predominantly sort
of white homogeneous that they wouldn't
have the same sort of multicultural
shoes with Islam and Sharia you're
saying it's across the whole country
it's across the whole country there I
mean don't get me wrong if you go
towards the north some parts of the
north like Lincoln share it has a high
predominant Muslim community but where
you find a high weten mostly cities
across the UK and you have to remember
that if you look at England compared to
America where we wear minut right so a
million girls and growing the number
it's growing it's not people to
understand that they talk about the
historical rates of these girls but
every day there's more right so what is
Maria stand for exactly it's mothers
against radical Islam and Sharia okay so
and your central focus is it namely
women's rights in the face of Islam it
if I'm gonna be really honest I'm a
little bit sick of the feminazi
I'm the true feminist I'm very happy to
be a woman and very proud to be a woman
and I don't mind jokes about women
because I would love it then I think
it's only fair that's very easy penises
are funny continue Wow yeah that's it's
not even the same color as the rest of
our body yeah women are a work of art
men not so much I accept it now if I
were to say something on the flip side
with women where you know men tend to be
physically stronger maybe a little more
durable that's sexist you're beautiful
were durable it's a jeep versus a
Ferrari to embrace the differences
between men and women I think that I see
you equal in your right and equal in my
right I don't think you're better than
me I think we're different women by
nature nurture whether we are mothers or
not we nurture and the one thing that
the whole world has in common
everybody has a mother everybody will
marry somebody who will become a mother
or they will have daughters and will
become mothers mothers are some one
thing that I felt connected right the
entire world not just England but
hi world well what about the idea of the
breaking down now of gender completely
where two daddies are the exact same as
a mother and a father as a mother do you
feel like that's belittling to the role
I don't think I personally don't have a
problem with it but then I'm quite
open-minded person so it really doesn't
faze me but I also don't think it's
wrong
I think the Radek culture that we have
in England has been quite damaging for
women mm-hmm I think that it's been
quite masculine for men yeah because I
think men by nature want to go out and
be the breadwinners and we've been made
to feel actually we must go out and be
more powerful we must get powerful jobs
and and there's nothing wrong with a
woman where it's go and get powerful job
right but if take time out to be mothers
it's very difficult to get back into the
work right so we've penalised at every
opportunity to a degree but I like the
differences in men and women and I
thinking something was [ __ ] bricks
you know as Nancy just hates men
this is true and we'll get to the big
irony because I want to give you the
full segment on that on the feminazi or
third wave feminists as Paul Joseph
Watson puts it and their irony in sort
of giving Islam a pass right but I will
say this in a personal level it's funny
you talk about that I we've talked about
that and it's one thing to talk about on
the program sort of from a third-person
perspective but my wife and I had a bit
of a scare and my wife works and I work
and I think like Carly Fiorina feminists
as anyone who has a choice if you choose
to work great if you choose to be at
stay-at-home mom either way your
feminist it's your choice yeah my wife
chooses to work but the agreement was
she didn't want to work when we have
children so we've known that and we had
a scare when we thought there might be
some little Crowder's coming into the
world and you know and it wasn't you
know I wouldn't be a furious about it I
just had happened and I thought I kind
of got excited for a bit and I said okay
and every what went through my head was
okay well you know what this is kind of
a relief because that means that I'm
going to be in charge of the work I'm
going to be in charge of winning the
bread and I know that the other duties
of taking care of the home the children
for the time being it gives me a
clear-cut view of what I need to do and
that
funny that went through my head within
the first minute and I felt a sense of
relief and I didn't know that about
myself until that situation arose and I
guess that means I'm a horrible
patriarch astir no I think it means
you're how dare you I know I don't know
how I could tell the difference between
your bed and mine but well it is tough
you never know I mean I will say this I
just wrote about it women get the short
end of the stick right now on the
transgender movement because you will
never be given the benefit of the doubt
again from a man hitting on you we will
be back with Tony of Maria slaughter
with Crowder's stay tuned Tony we are
back sorry that took a weird turn but I
wanted to give you a full segment to
talk about feminism and Islam so it's
not quite there yet here in the United
States we've observed the UK from afar
you started off by saying you couldn't
send the feminazis how does that tie in
now to women against Sharia and Islam
it's always him because feminazis
refused to stand up for all women they
choose to go to the street there was a
worldwide women March and the chap who
does title my things for me because he's
far cleverer than me and I hate to admit
this true he went along and was handing
out leaflets and they were screaming
literally do you have a womb do you have
and I said but did you not think to do
anything so what about every woman who
had cervical cancer and had everything
taken away does that make a less of a
woman no but what they won't do is stand
up for women who being beaten because of
Sharia law right which is operating in
our country right now now people say
that we reported on it no one believed
us when we reported on I think the
number was 81 or 82 Sharia Courts and
there's over a hundred now over a
hundred three across and that's not
including the ones operating within
mosques right I'm not supposed to be
operate with the loss but are they will
try to tell you that they only deal with
marriage divorce etcetera but I've one
particular lady who I ratings on my part
with which is the birthplace of freedom
of speech and she had much lead among
the died their dad said to her you must
get
get married she went Pakistan fell in
love with a guy they came to England as
soon as they arrived back in England
they know how to fence
and he said to her you are nothing but
filthy British who far what does that
mean who far is it's an insulting way of
saying you're not Muslim
oh that's funny that sounds like a
bodily function you can imagine why it
threw me off right away if you think
about it in those days
yes what's funny we had a woman on here
who in the States even who had to leave
Islam and we had the first time we were
to cover up her face her voice and she
talked about how oh yeah my husband
wanted divorce me he just needed to say
divorce divorce divorce three times our
marriage was that yeah and she said
that's the thing a lot of people don't
realize most Muslim marriages aren't
really recognized and if they are
recognized for tax purposes
that's not respected within the mosque
it still comes down to Sharia she
married within mm-hmm but he divorced
her within Sharia law right leaving her
now he took all our money he went back
to Pakistan after she'd spent three
years of being beaten and investing her
life savings into businesses he took
everything because when a man divorces
the woman if they have children of a
certain age if they're above I believe
it's coming up to four six their
children automatically go to the men and
a woman that's now saying that so they
if they want to divorce our husbands
they lose their children they lose their
money thank you everything now is this a
lot of people I can already see in the
youtube comment section saying your
sensationalizing you're just looking for
a reason to discriminate against Islam
how widespread of a problem is it does
this actually pose a problem to like a
republic like the united sisters it
actually pose a problem to the freedom
the democracy that is a place like
solutely i mean we have a problem with
our freedom and democracy anyway we've
been beaten so much with the politically
incorrect stake that you didn't even say
I mean I had a there was a lovely going
hi
black man came up and and said to me you
know he doesn't agree with Sharia law
and he thinks all women should be
cherished I said well done well said
young man exactly as it should be
however a lot of people don't realize
these that if you say you're a black man
and I'm a proud black man everybody will
go and I'll be the first to say and so
you should be but if I say I'm a proud
white woman I'm a white supremacist
white privileged I'm a racist fascist
Nazi bigot I get death threats every day
I best break me sodomized me I get these
on a regular basis I would think rate
would go with the sodomizing territory I
think it's a bit redundant if they're
telling you both well no I think that
actually the sodomizing is more of a
humiliation tactic it's funny you say
that because that was I would grew up in
Montreal long people don't know that so
much more similar to Europe than where I
am now in the United States and my dad
got cut off by a cab driver and so we
were in the car I mean we almost got cut
off right downtown Montreal you know
into a parked car very dangerous so my
dad cut him off and I remember my dad
yelled roll down the window and yelled
yeah cabbie
[ __ ] and then the guy gets out and he
pulls out his cane and he goes like this
like motions like a cane going and he
goes I am going to eff you and your
family before you go home I am going to
eff you and I never said Nocona what is
this
and I remember speaking with my Muslim
friend about it and he said yeah yeah
that's actually it sort of like a
domineering thing it's a cultural thing
and it was so weird to me because I just
thought like your insult is yelling I'm
gay and to him it was it was the
ultimate realize is that rape is used as
a form of jihad that's exactly what it
is used for and if you think about the
word rape and then the word word Islam
Islam means subjugation domination
control right then you think about rape
subjugation domination control I hadn't
heard the the subjugation control part I
had heard you know submission to God
it's how they explained it to me in
school which was different from what I
had read in the Quran but that was sort
of their say
[ __ ] you're saying is that the actual
translation of Islam yes they anybody
will tell you that that is exactly why
it's not means subjugation domination
control and there is also a word up for
their belief don't quote me on this
because I might get the word wrong but I
believe the word is quarry which
basically means sex slave
yeah so they can take what they want
right hand possesses and if you believe
you are if they believe they are in a
state of war with the West
therefore these girls who are
predominate and we had a problem with a
lot of seat girls being taunted and then
it moved to white girls predominately
white girls and and these girls the
things that have been done to him are
you could you could not imagine the
women that contacted me themselves now
what about people who would say this is
just these are just gangs looking for an
excuse can this be directly attributed
to in an alarming motivation in my
opinion yes absolutely because if you
look at the history of Islam I mean you
ever in America are very very
intelligent man called dr. Warner mm-hmm
which surprises me because he is an
American doctor all I know I get words
coming from you let your number one
draft pick get away in the United States
and we came back and now you have to
fake fake it out like well at least
we're still better in soccer i I get
where you're coming from I'll take the
jabs go ahead I know I just I just call
it a bunch of a bunch of sprites running
around with pink jerseys and buns in
there but I don't want to ruin your
point true but I do think that dr.
Filmore warned if you want if you want
some of his YouTube videos that he's
made where he breaks it down you can see
the connection and there is a connection
and what people won't know about me and
I make no I've no shame in this at all I
myself was gang-raped when I was fifteen
I know exactly what rape does I know the
devastation it causes when these girls
are raped
they are told they are filthy white
trash not at any point has any of these
coins been reported as being racially
motivated they will not acknowledge it
if being racist these girls have been
let down by the social services care
homes counselors police police won't act
because of political correctness because
if they act 13 racist yeah and I would
imagine they probably try and deal with
that in their own Sharia Courts well no
because he's a rapist of white girls I
mean I'm not saying Muslim women aren't
being raped but I believe that they are
the differences in this long you cannot
refuse your husband sex therefore you
cannot actually be raped if you are
raped you must produce four male
witnesses right now if you can't produce
four male witnesses you're an adulterer
now when this happened to you were they
were they Muslim men they weren't no but
what I ended up I became runaway and I
lived on the streets for a year in
London and I encountered a young girl
who was being prostituted by Pakistani
men she was 12 years old and they've got
hooked on drugs basically she'd been
raped by a father she couldn't go home
they took her in will give you somewhere
nice to stay somewhere warm to stay feed
you but then they got hooked on drugs
and started prostituting her out because
now looks like she owes them money for
the drugs well I would say this and I
don't disagree with you'd all have if
you follow any of the stuff that I've
done Islam Mohammed was a horrible human
being who committed heinous acts and and
it was a hateful person but I will say
that what you've just described doesn't
sound all that different from a pimp in
the United States so what's right but
would you be able to argue and prove
that as a portion of the populace that
either it is a more common occurrence
for Muslim men in the UK to rape target
white women or that they're not
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law if someone who looked like you had
done it yeah I could send you link after
link after link after link after link I
could inundate you with
which would show you that we had for
example a man raped an 11 year old child
mostly man raped an 11 year old child
and will spread joy because his wife
couldn't speak English really oh yeah I
mean I could say how does that happen
how does it how does someone who you
know I don't know the exact judicial
system how it works there I think it's
similar to Canada where they still wear
the funny wigs I know that do they how
do they justify that kind of a ruling
because the the race card is Julie
played Islamophobia Karl but she's now
being played on a regular basis if we
also now are running we've got a
shortage on presidents bases so there's
no room in the prisons for so much so
we're actually moving hardened criminals
into open prisons to accommodate more
criminals
we've got immigration by the boatload
literally by the boatload trans get into
the country and if you look at the
boatloads of immigrants trying to get in
via France and Italy you'll note
something that these are young men these
are not women or children the elderly or
the infirm why they meant why are they
young men if you were in a country that
was war-torn and you were fleeing you
take the weakest with you first the
women the children the elderly good
point that is not what we gain we're
getting boatloads of young men that are
able to climb
the inside of lorries our lorry drivers
are being fined thousands of pounds when
immigrants are getting into their
lorries even though they don't know
they're there
the lorry driver gets fined thousands of
pounds because of it these men in mines
are nothing more than soldiers because
they believe they're at war with this so
what do you do when you're at war you
sending them in well that's very
interesting and actually bringing you
some other points so for those of you
listening terrestrially Lauder with
Crider comm we are going to have an
extended uncensored web cut here with
Tony
we will go on for as long as she wants
obviously with a sensitive topic like
this so terrestrially I will be back
with fun dip everyone else louder with
Crowder calm stay tuned
okay Tony so
here online there are no more breaks
sorry about that we have to keep the
lights on a couple of things that you
brought up interesting Lee so they break
they're just sending and I'm sure you
would have data to back that up I'm
assuming right the young men right I you
know I just have I have to do my job
they're not just like let it go past me
what happened what is happening with the
women who are being left and does that
is that changing the fabric of their
population is it mostly women in these
countries is there a disproportionate
ratio of women know that these women in
the Islamic countries are really seeing
and they're mostly covered in burkas and
they are really nothing more than
breeding machines I mean Egypt for
example as low at the age of marriage
down to as young as you can marry a
child a six month yeah now you can't
vaginally penetrate that child but you
can find that job okay I'm afraid to ask
go ahead explain this sawing of a child
is where the man places his penis
between the thighs and brings himself
off between the thighs okay and they'll
do this with really really young would
it be plausible that here's my question
seems they got the cultural thing is it
a common enough cultural practice that
let's say Mohammed would have died
six-year-old Aisha no he would have had
sex with are you sure because he would
have been permitted to a new have sex
with that okay and what's the back it's
horrible but what's the backing behind
that like is this I mean I think they
but I've never read that in the Quran
like ah you know during the rear read
the Hadees okay I will I have I'll be
honest I've read the hadith in the sense
that it's very hard to comprehend today
well I've what that's what I was gonna
say I've read the hadith in the
sensitive read books that have
interpreted the hadith both this sort of
throw Islam that they were giving out up
the Muslim college club and then from
people like you've mentioned I think
people like Robert Spencer because it's
very hard to follow to just go in and
read it yourself you have so noisy I
felt a fee why
they and a MIDI right each of those are
different sects of Islam or different
sects of muscles each of those follow a
different set of four deeds right but
each of them will argue over whose
Hadees are the genuine Hadees right but
yeah they're these are nothing more than
words
supposedly heard by Muhammad himself
Rowe said by Muhammad right they're not
actually words of Muhammad they're
Chinese whispers well I get it I did the
Quran challenge and when I talk about
the use the hadith you know for his last
words condemning the Christians and Jews
he had some come and go we don't even
believe that but the fact is for the
longest time even though sects of
Muslims did and that's changed and it's
sort of the cafeteria Muslim you know
you're picking and choosing I think
everyone would agree that when taken
within current context Mohammed was a
pretty bad dude and even if you think
Jesus was imaginary it's not at all the
same kind of an example you could have a
bunch of people out now mimicking Jesus
and we wouldn't have a problem they were
mimicking Mohammed you'd have terrorism
that to me is a legitimate point of view
that's always the view with I've helped
but you talk about these sort of sexual
practices and I'm always curious now is
this across all sects what you just said
would that be agreed upon across most
mainstream sectors of Islam I mean
there's a really lovely chap that he's
speaking to who originates from Iraq
he's fluent Iraqi speaks fluent Arabic
he reads learn Arabic and he's made a
few YouTube videos which own he's
uploaded which he breaks down pedophilia
within the Quran itself and not just the
age of Aisha but further so and I mean I
remember it off the top of my head as I
keep saying I am blonde so bear with me
but there are you can actually watch it
and then listen to and you can see where
he's pointing out it's breaking it down
he's showing you the quotes direct from
the Koran
you've only got us also look at Pakistan
Pakistan has a massive problem of little
boys as young as eight years old being
raped by up to 13 men at a time right
that's happening but everywhere you look
where it's Army's rape is
well you'd have Muslims who argument
homosexuality is just is wrong it's
outlawed under Islam so they would say
rape of young boys is not as Lamas quote
in the Quran that justifies sex with a
boy with a boy not a grown man okay that
sex with a boy doesn't might be gay
right I don't know how that works
exactly I'm not I'm a little fuzzy in
the math it makes you gay when you've
got a hairy chest or something I'm not
quite sure 100% myself but I do know
that the guy that I speak to he's very
knowledgeable with anymore he's telling
me right and I do make a point of asking
questions because I don't want to know
what I'm dealing with
well what can you do about it so you've
started Maria so it's sort of what can
you do about it in the UK what's your
call-to-action to people on this issue
my call to action first of all has to be
knowledge knowledge is power right
people have to one have to know this is
happening they do have to accept that
it's happening it's the same as and
newspapers that our media will never
call these men Muslim they will call
them Asian that offends me greatly these
men are not sick
Hindu I'm not saying you don't get the
occasional seek the rapes or white
people that raped me took some time
where you know Jimmy Savile Stewart we
know we have rapists the only difference
is it's not sanctioned by the religion
of that person right or raping because
it is sanctioned by the very faith that
you follow right and the very law that
you follow so the point of morality is
first of all we we want to get I have
got a lot of women contacting me right
now who had been brutally raped by not
one man but sometimes one particular
girl for example and when she was 13
years old I believe we started when she
was 12 13 they groomed her they then
raped her
they then prostituted her out to uncle's
brothers fathers sons
they were related or with they would
literally take her from the length and
breadth of the UK take her to a flat one
would walk behind bomber walking from
she would be made to lay on a bed
she wasn't permitted to get off of the
bed she wasn't permitted to why she
wasn't permitted to use the toilet
they came in they raped her repeatedly
up to 20 men at a time she then started
to severely help self home and I mean
severely Marie just to the point of it
being absolutely upon for her not for me
but for her and she hoped that that
would deter them but one of matchi
family so exciting he took it upon
himself to take a blade and cut her
whilst raping her
yeah for many many years this will start
undoing and a lot of it is taxi drivers
up and down the country taxi drivers are
heavily involved in the rape of these
girls and now Rotherham are saying taxi
drivers must have CCTV in their cameras
and suddenly we've got a mass
demonstration in mothering right
taxi drivers saying basically if these
girls want to be protected let them pay
for the camera typically we're not
having him and they protested about and
cameras and then you have stupid people
in the UK sorry you were protesting uber
wouldn't it be great to listen I don't
know where you line up politically
wouldn't it be great if you guys had a
second amendment in these women would be
able to protect themselves
think about this don't you have to at
least go have to explain the right to
bear arms the right to protect yourself
that a woman should have a right to have
a loaded gun in her purse to be able to
protect herself from rape because it's
very well understood that the only
chance a woman has the only chance woman
has against a man is being armed you're
systematically putting women in position
being unable to defend themselves
against rape and I know you know that's
a perfect example of people from the UK
think oh this crazy United States gun
culture but we'd a situation with my
wife we had someone who tried to break
into her house while she was in the
house knew she was in the house was
stalking the house had been casing it
out for a while and I won't get into the
logistics but my wife is a second
Amendment woman so I
can't imagine people facing this in the
UK not wanting more women to have the
ability to protect themselves
unfortunately we have a government that
says excuse me extremely warming here
and we don't actually have that rights
that right foot you are right we are it
is no longer safe for girls and me I've
got a daughter of 20 and she will let me
know and she's a ride somewhere she lets
me know she's with her boyfriend I know
where she is what times to come home I
don't let her walk home alone but I
won't let get taxi it isn't safe for
women anymore
in England would you want to see a right
to bear arms for people in need for
law-abiding citizens in the UK to be
able to protect themselves it would have
to be done I mean I don't believe in
having these okay great you know 12-bore
shotguns but I do think that women
should have the right to be able to I
mean we're not even allowed to carry
pepper spray right you know so we've got
nothing to protect ourselves so
personally yes I would like to see it
but I also know government is weak and
out Prime Minister even weaker to the
point of being an amoeba he doesn't have
a backbone but they're stronger than you
and they're stronger than you without
guns and that's always the reason I'm
taking an opportunity here for when
people say that Americans are crazy it's
so this doesn't happen and even though
Sharia has come in the United States and
political correctness is happening you
are talking what was that yeah I did a
video in Dearborn we have it in Dearborn
but it stays in Dearborn within
themselves and I mean we have over 300
million guns in this country that is a
big failsafe it's a big failsafe against
a government that if it were to start
saying hey we're going to insan' give
some kind of multiculturalism rights to
Muslims to rape women we're not going to
prosecute them and it allows women to
protect themselves if you look at places
where concealed carry laws have been
passed in the United States and the same
laws that get trotted out by Pierce
Morgan and they talk about mass
shootings despite the fact that most
public shootings occur in gun-free zones
with a little simple handgun not the big
scary black rifle but a revolver or a
little semi-automatic where those laws
have been passed women are safer rapes
are down dramatically specifically
carjackings or
dramatically and I just want to hear
these stories in the UK I think I would
so much rather read would be rapists
shot dead in a ditch than a woman raped
well III can't dispute that and let me
just add just for the record
yes Morgan Rielly as a complaint not to
us we really don't have the greatest of
respect for that man at the best of
times and he was very quick to run out
there to get American money right and
then talk about the great old England
well he was quick to leave it so I don't
have a great deal of respect for him
anyway and I do think the women should
have the right to be able to bear arms
to protect themselves but we know that's
never gonna happen so we have to take
other mission measures some of those
measures have got to be that women have
got to start standing up in mass
together right now I believe that the
paralysing in women but the strength
lies in men mm-hmm
so he's said of it being a male fronted
organization being pushed to the
forefront I believe men have as much
right to be a feminist as I do
absolutely yeah I'm not like the
feminists to the male feminists who just
wrote for New York Maggie I don't know
if you read that for he said as a
feminist he allows his wife to cheat on
him because not allowing an open
marriage would be anti-feminist and I'm
thinking you're just you're just
enabling your wife to act like at all
right right exactly no he doesn't but
she does that was his thing because he's
a strong feminist and he would never
forbid yes exactly he's just a weak man
here's something I'd like to sort of
firstly where can people go to find
Maria's more about it there is a
Facebook and a Twitter okay
finest on both of them and what I do
want is for one the reason I we want to
speak to you is because America doesn't
realize what he has coming to them yeah
and no offense meant but you were a
little bit slow coming in on the the
world wars you know we don't want you to
be a bit slow when it comes to this we
need you to agree I think that if you
don't understand what is happening in
England there likes a place
newton tower hamlets where they're they
saying that there are no no-go zones in
england trust me now there are no go
zones in england right well I think it's
important for English people to
recognize you're only people like you
you're only allies are the religious
American right not because they're crazy
and they hate Islam but because they are
Pro freedom they understand the
Constitution or libertarians but the
problem with things like Sharia law the
prompt listen we've been talking about
this for a long time but leftists in
America our administration they're
constantly saying no this is
fear-mongering it's not true and they
point to the UK as an example for health
care for crime I mean they constantly
tried out the UK and Australia for crime
they'd go look no gun crime they don't
talk about the rapes that go unreported
they don't talk about the violent crime
the stabbings and muggings that are
through the roof so we are
systematically lied to here in the
country and I hope that people likes you
in the UK who see it get that that's not
coming from all Americans it is coming
from the American left and it's a
proactive lying we have left in our
country too right and they are apologist
they are pieces and they are cowards
right through the bees they know the
truth but they don't want to accept
truth because accepting the truth means
they will be called a racist right that
they fear more than anything else yeah
terrifies it but as I've said to people
I get cold toe constantly now I have got
more some friends and I have Muslim
women who come to me and I help them
till I give them support I give them
guidance sure I help them where I come
so I'm not one of these that go I'm only
here for the English women I will
support any woman no matter what creed
color creation religion even though I'm
an atheist
I took a Muslim woman into my house
because her family were trying to people
trafficker right by sending them out to
Somalia to marry a man bring him back
into the UK a few months later they'll
act alike d'like off you go get yourself
another husband bring into the UK when
she said no they won't opacity a
intended to sell for 50
thousand pounds she said no again her
cousin attacked her he intended to kill
her which would have been an honor
basically well yes and I don't want I
don't want to cut you up I don't I get
to Farfan in anecdotal stories because I
think for people who don't believe you
the data and the overall picture is
going to compel the more I do want to
ask you something though personally
before we go as someone who is you you
were open about it and you can tell me
from crossing any lines you mentioned
being gang-raped which is you know
heart-stoppingly shocking right now you
also said that you hated the feminazi so
you people like Lena Dunham out there be
or things being taught in college that
any regrettable sex is rape that any PIV
they call it penis and vagina is rape
that any drunken sex is rape because a
woman doesn't have the right to consent
Lena Dunham claims she was raped when
she did a bunch of drugs xanax
consented and then later regretted it
that's the big culture right now the
microaggression culture and people like
me who say well that's that's really
belittling to women who were actually
raped are considered rape apologists
where do you line up on the idea of rape
culture and what constitutes an actual
rate because that's up for debate now I
mean I was unfortunate when I was
gang-raped I was gang-raped by four men
there five men and a woman so I was
raped by a woman to it and the law in
this country says a woman cannot rape a
woman because she can't have penetrative
sex because she doesn't have penis
therefore she can't penetrate therefore
they don't class it's rape it's sexual
assault sexual abuse but not right okay
now for those women we get them here
where they go out on a night out they
three parts pissed putting it quite
bluntly
they then cop off with some young mom
off they go they have a bit of fun start
to sober up a big thing
bugger they didn't want that to happen
he raped me no he didn't rape here at
all right you are stupid enough to get
so drunk you didn't know what you were
doing I do believe that yes we can all
go and have a drink
you get falling down drunk then all
you're doing don't blame the guy you've
been coming on to all night that you've
gone by
to his place with and you've ended up
having sex well if you have not got
quite that drunk you would have gone
home right well I think that's
reasonable I think people would say well
guys and I do think that guys should be
better than that and should try and you
know chivalry shouldn't be dead but it's
not the same kind of a motivation as
forceful gang rape so much as both
people drunk and you know not really
knowing what they're doing so would you
say that that is a disservice to women
of who are victims of actually yeah I
think it's and you also have to remember
this there's also different types of
rape you've got grooming where they
could bring me for a long period of time
that the man who was the ling'ring
leader with me accrue me for it from the
age of ten three eight to fifteen before
he decided to do we did mm-hm
cuz then I trusted him implicitly I was
never gonna doubt him I was never gonna
feel unsafe with him so it was all
planned down to the last detail and then
you've got the guy on the streets who
grabs a woman in in a bus show where
drugs drugs that be on a bus tour and
rapes it there are different there's
opportunist rapists
there's grooming rapists right I do
believe that no means no I believe in
many a woman says no I don't care how
drunk you are the word no means no no
stop end off but I don't believe that
you can go to the point where he's
actually on top inside then you go now I
change my get off you just raped me well
no he didn't right I don't think they
were disservice to genuine break victims
and we have a big enough problem so for
women and girls here right now to be
believed this is the thing that
infuriates me when somebody comes to you
and tells you they've been raped you
have to believe them right that's really
important yeah and it's getting to the
point where a lot of people aren't you
have mattress girl you know who have you
been following that story they're okay
mattress girl she went around with her
mattress on her back claiming she'd been
raped well one does right if you've been
raped to carry a mattress on your back
and you walk around campus and you don't
press charges and you tell everyone
about your rape and they unearth the the
boy formally complained in front of I
don't know what you call it some sort of
college tribunal which is basically
you're guilty until proven innocent
for men right now if rape if someone
accuses it generally speaking or guilty
this is one of the rare instances where
they said it really doesn't seem that
way
they found texts of her demanding that
he have that demanding anal sex from him
telling him what he wanted talking about
how great the sex was before he was no
longer interested in her you could see a
history of her becoming aggravated with
him and then she went out claimed she
was raped mattress on her back mattress
girl so this girl was held out as a
feminist hero for a long time and still
is if he go to Huffington Post mattress
girl at Columbia a lot of people hear
this story and don't realize that it was
not rape but this was a girl who was
known to do drugs who was very sexually
demanding and the guy flat out said no
it didn't happen and he was found not
guilty that's a big story here and even
with everything being said we still say
that guy's a rapist you have across
colleges in this country they call PIV
any PIV can technically be rape at any
point because women do to societal
subjugation actually have no ability to
consent to sex so there's this thing now
pushed in people like Lena Dunham the
new feminists they call it rape culture
and you may not necessarily be aware of
it in the UK because you have an actual
problem with rape culture right now here
we have to create one where every man is
a rapist sometimes we do America's gonna
go I don't like her she hates America I
don't never been would love to go but I
do think that a situation like that I
don't know the story so obviously I
can't make a judgement without reading
it but that does what that does that's
an insult to people like me mm-hmm I
find that offensive and I would call
around there's not even close to being a
feminist more of an ignorant idiot and a
bit of a pillar they should have shut
her mouth when she couldn't get what she
wanted backed off and left him alone
right you know but we do have places
here where you do get the woman who goes
out she's married and she gets off with
somebody and one thing leads to another
and she panics about the husband finding
out and by the time it gets to call she
the advance what I really didn't write
me right doesn't happen very often and
it's very rare that happens because I
think we've especially right now because
I mean we've had fathers go to flats to
try and get their 13 year old daughters
out of the homes of these Pakistani
men's houses mm-hmm and the police have
been called binder farmers and they've
arrested the daughters for underage
drinking arrested two fathers for being
there and and barge it into the flat but
the most amenable friend right you know
these are the kind of things we're
facing easy is this kant's this has been
going on historically now I can go back
like I said when I was on the streets
that goal was 12 years old she was being
pimped out they were Pakistani they were
muscling when she think a client one
night had beaten her quite badly mm-hmm
and I did the only thing I could do I
went to a police officer now when you
live out homes on the streets you don't
use your own name and which is why I get
called Tony because my name is that she
Antoinette okay and she was I never knew
her real name but I always knew as
Claire and because I had taken him out
of action by getting the police to take
her and obviously I don't know what
happened to after that I don't know she
survived I don't know she got treatment
foster home adopted I have no idea right
I am but they then came after me now I
was on several occasions attacked and
beaten with boots kicked punched my hair
dragged down I was dragged on streets
and down alleys it was actually the act
of a homeless man and he charged it on
one like that that saved my life no and
so I do know and I know when they were
doing it I was told then I was white
trash
there was a Whitehall that I would now
be every Muslim month toy that is what
they wanted I was going to pay but
because her day now became my day right
now I'm lucky enough I'm a survivor I'm
not a victim and I really don't want
anybody to go
poor woman because trust me I'm one
feisty English bird and I will not stand
for anybody's nonsense now but I had to
fight to become a survivor because what
he did to me was soul destroying my
family never knew until I was in my
mid-twenties so the silence that they
use is this thing of telling parents you
know they get a girl into a position
they they get to perhaps expose her body
they take the photo well if it happens
here in the States two minutes it's not
always Islamic lead Riven but like
you're saying there's a culture and you
see it in Islamic culture in any
Islamically run country you see it in
the way that women are trained you see
it in genital mutilation what kind of a
culture I always talk I won't let you go
through this but my dad and I've always
talked about this what kind of a
absolute wimp are you as a man that you
have no confident in your sexual
abilities to pleasure your woman that
you just decide to do away with her
capability to do it any way she wouldn't
know anyway because we had it mutilated
I mean you must have no faith in your
skills as a lover to do that video
pretty much along the same lines where I
said to the truth of it is that you
wouldn't you you have to right because
actually you have no idea what a
clipless is because you take that off
that's right journey and we have I
believe you I don't get the mentality
it's half the fun I try and set the high
score well we like to get that now to
give you a little bit of direction just
to help you along the way men are we
directions and they never like to ask
anyone do they no but I think we're
getting somewhere in the region of six
hundred cases of FGM
in the last I believe you something like
the last two to three months there have
been 600 and we're also getting 400
little girls have gone missing in in a
space of a period of time this is in the
UK yeah that we believe have been taken
out the UK to be female general EMU
slated and they're now performing on
babies we've had well that's important
to know because people will say and not
one not one case it's got to court and
been challenged that's horrible and it's
important to know because you'll have
people say well there are places within
er
Christian countries where people are
being you know African countries for
general to be new needle that is true
but nowhere in the UK or the United
States do you have Christian sects that
are mutilating gendell's mass and of
course everywhere in Islamic countries
let's not deny an actual trend here Tony
we have to let you go because of all our
upgraded technology is acting up so
people can find you on Facebook and on
Twitter correct Maria's ma RI a s yes
with a dot in between Tony thank you so
much for coming on we appreciate it and
we'll get that up hopefully people go
check it out and I'm glad to see you
using you know what can be some horrible
personal experiences to hopefully help
other people we absolutely will ladder
with Crowder Tony go check out Maria's
and stay tuned if you enjoyed this video
you're not a feminist so you can
subscribe because you probably won't be
triggered though you might be triggered
I don't know everyone gets triggered by
something nowadays depends where you
line up on the LGBTQ AI F and a silent v
everyone's welcome but at some point
just know we'll probably make fun if you
click one of the videos are subscribed
or or don't you do it you don't have to
that's okay too but we'll just make fun
of you behind your back